hello everybody I just wanted to let you
guys know that you are all handsome
and/or beautiful people you're amazing
you're gonna go on to do incredible
things you're a star baby about other
than that I also wanted to let you guys
know that I will be out of town for a
week um two weeks from now from June
10th until the 17th I will be down at
cyndago headquarters making videos with
them for a full weekend these aren't
gaming videos these are gonna be full
sketch comedy videos that you're gonna
love and if you haven't seen cyndago
already I've worked with them before and
I've been linking their them for quite
some time now because they are amazingly
talented guys that I've already done a
project with I narrated a horror story
where I manipulate the world around them
it's very sinister and absolutely
hilarious they did an incredible job
want to see it you can click here here
here or here or right on my face and
you'll be taken to the video right away
don't have annotations on you can click
the link in the description seriously
watch this video it's pretty amazing and
check out their other videos while
you're there and be sure to subscribe to
send to go so that you know exactly when
my videos with them are released and a
while I'm down there don't have to worry
about lacking videos from me because I
will have all the videos set up and
scheduled for release and I will try to
take my computer down with me so that if
there's any problems I'll be able to
record something on the fly and be sure
to follow me on Twitter and Facebook
because I'm gonna be posting regular
updates one there so remember click here
here here here and on my face or in the
description to see that video that we've
worked on already it's awesome
they're incredible I love their videos
to death and you will too also check out
their views yada yada yada you got all
of that your beautiful handsome awesome
people so thanks again everybody for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye
click here
afraid of what you'll hear